hello and welcome everyone this is guest
stream number 53.1 at the Active
inference Institute it's August 23rd
2023 we're going to be having a
presentation followed by a discussion
around the recent work of Alexi
tulcinski a case for a Chaos Theory
inclusion in neuropsychoanalytic
modeling so if you're watching live
please feel free to add any questions
into the live chat otherwise we will now
have the presentation followed by a
discussion with our excellent panelists
so thank you everybody for joining and
Alexi to you for the presentation
um thank you uh Daniel
um
thank you Mark for finding the time I'm
very uh grateful and excited to talk
about this thank you Andrea uh we're in
Albert I hope maybe Mike will join us
and uh thank you Daniel and active
inference Institute for organizing this
meeting
so uh can you see the slides
yeah okay so I'll just uh receive them
um this is the outline of the talk I'll
share some preliminary comments and talk
briefly about assumptions in the current
models summarize the data talk about
free energy Principle formulations as
compatible with chaos and talk about
some future developments and hopefully
we can discuss that I'm very much
looking forward to have more questions
than answers
I'd like to start with what Mike 11 uh
taught me I guess is just why it's
important to me the most important thing
is the clinical applications I think
that
with your work Mark and with yakpanzip's
work we have been moving uh away from
dualism over the course of some time but
I think the other big determinants is
still highly prevalent and dominant and
I do think it influences power uh
clinical work diagnosis and
Psychotherapy and assessments and I
think that it may be beneficial for some
of the harder conditions we work with to
consider including non-linear framework
that's my main focus and this is the
link to the preprint and the paper is
published fully in your recycle analysis
Journal
some of it is a discussion with this
foundational paper that umark wrote the
new project for a scientific psychology
General scheme which is a perhaps
revision a Revival of Freud's famous
paper project for scientific psychology
and
um
I'd like to give you a credit Mark that
you have been opening conversations
between disciplines that hadn't been
talking to each other prior to your
efforts such as psychoanalysis and uh
neurosciences you've been doing for more
than 20 years with great success in the
same spirit I wanted to mention that
Society for chaos theory in psychology
exists since 91 which is one of the
first conference happened about less
than 20 years than the first conference
on chaos in Lake Italy around Lake Italy
Lake Cuomo in Italy in 76 which was
mostly physicists at that time and then
psychologists joined and I've attended
the recent conference in Toronto which
was absolutely wonderful and I met
extraordinary clinicians and scientists
and I think that it would be beneficial
to open that dialogue as well and maybe
there is a wall between us to consider
demolishing the wall
um
um in terms of intent for the paper Your
Mark pointed out to me that you've had
an exchange with Robert gallitzer Levy
for those of you who may not know him
he's a psychoanalyst from Chicago a
psychologic writer and a teacher who
wrote a book on non-linear
psychoanalysis and there's a deserves a
lot of credit for his advocacy and you
know he's sharing his thoughts
he posed the question to you mark of
possibly considering non-linear
components in that seminal paper or
project for scientific psychology
and to which you responded that the key
point in such discussion was whether the
mental apparatus was indeed non-linear
so I took your comment as a task as a
challenge if you wish and decided to
write a paper about it
I don't know if the data presented is
sufficient but I tried
and very clearly I don't intend to
contradict or criticize you know that
would be funny of me to do I am hopeful
maybe to add a branch of this tree that
you're growing
clinical and theoretical tree and should
you consider it worthwhile to go in this
direction we wouldn't have to change
very much because this is the paper by
Tristan Lancelot De Costa and others
called stochastic chaos and Mark of
blankets our financial principle is
compatible with the uh chaotic
attracting set what I thought was not
present just yet was a formulation where
the attracting set experiences a phase
transition
and I took Liberty to ask Carl about it
and he shared some very nice thoughts
that I wrote uh with his permission
share at the end of The Talk
um
I'd like to cite Maxwell ramstead whom
you know and his colleagues from the
paper and Basin mechanics are physics
Often by beliefs where they talk about
Dynamics mechanics and principles and in
physics uh you know Kepler's work is
descriptive it shows you know what the
orbits of heavenly bodies are
mechanics are the how of the Dynamics
this is Newton's laws and principles are
prescriptive they are about why things
work this way there's a certain
hierarchy in physics where you could
derive the second law of Newton from
principle of least action and then if
you have initial conditions you can
calculate the Dynamics
the reason I'm mentioning that is I
think Mark your new project for
scientific psychology is a high road
it seems to start from first principles
such as the free energy principle and
you seem to derive things down from
there
so I thought why not try to see how the
low road may look like if in addition to
these derivations and deductions and
Declaration of what entropy should be in
the brain what if we measure it in
animal studies and human studies in
health and pathology and see what the
data shows and whether or not the low
road meets The High Road in the middle
or perhaps something may need to be
added
I also like to clarify why I spend time
in the paper talking about obvious
things for everybody here the axioms and
postulates and I'm quoting here Edward
Frankel who is a mathematician at
Berkeley
and you know uh Michael will forgive me
but you know a Viewpoint is that one can
say that some parts of biology can be
seen as based on chemistry which can be
seen as based on physics which can be
seen as based in mathematics so how do
things work in mathematics we know that
Carl Kristin likes to translate nearly
everything he works on into the language
of mathematics
classically there's something called a
formal system which we can
metaphorically compare to building a
house so the foundation of the house is
a set of axioms that has certain
qualities and then we build things up
using the logic of Aristotle and we
derive things like theorems
an example would be including geometry
which is on the plane that is based on
five axioms of Euclid that's the
foundation and then you could derive
things like Pythagorean theorem
now if we were to change just one of the
axioms in the foundation the entire
house changes
an example would be the fifth Axion of
Euclid that parallel lines essentially
don't intersect if you change that then
we could have a house of on the sphere
which is lobojevski Roman geometry and
meridians of the Earth are parallel and
they intersect but you could have
parabolic shape where parallel lights
also intersect
so we'll have an entirely different
framework and it may be naive to expect
the theorem to look the same the
figurative theorem if we you know put it
on the sphere is different the formula
is different
um I'm mentioning that is because I I
love multidisciplinarity and I think
that's the way of the future
with that sometimes when when we cross
over into another discipline such as you
know psychologists you know taking
mathematicals or physics ideas then we
we may occasionally forget this formal
system thing for example when we see
things like human beings resist or
violate the second law of thermodynamics
then we uh the second law was formally
related for Clovis systems in the state
of equilibrium such as a sealed chamber
of gas and human beings are neither
closed nor in the state of equilibrium
so it doesn't quite apply it's a
different formal system one needs
physics development systems to make a
statement like that so again in
mathematics because you mark seem to
have taken us deeply in the native
mathematics in your project you have
differential equations for Action
perception Precision you have you know
Mark of blankets random dynamical
systems you know equivalences partial
derivatives then
in mathematics people fix the set of
axioms they fix the definitions and then
they build a theory right
um so I want to be clear I want to
clarify what are the axioms in the
theory that is built what is the
foundation
and in the effort of time maybe I'll
talk about just one of them
uh which is Freud psychic determinism
and this is a question for me not an
answer I wanted to ask you because I am
assuming
uh whether you uh kept this Axiom or you
changed it
the Freud said in the Psychopathology of
everyday life that there is nothing
arbitrary or undetermined in the psychic
life there's different versions of this
statement and it has been repeated by
generations of psychoanalysts over 100
years and it became very entrenched it's
sort of a cultural Meme and a major
tenet of psychoanalysis
if I were to give an illustration
perhaps those of us who are not in in
psychologic therapy then
let's imagine a analytic therapist
hearing a patient
who intends to say same with an S but
they use the word shame
right
so such a phenomenon you know first of
all I think psychodynamics psychologic
therapists would probably say that's not
an accident
okay accident is is not naughty you know
used term in psychoanalysis and secondly
they will probably infer of what it
might mean
for example infer along the lines of
unconscious or emotional Dynamics
emotional conflict somebody else may
infer that it may have
neuropsychological reasons somebody else
may infer that it probably is a migraine
but what you might will not hear in
psychodynamic culture is that that was
you know an accident that it was due to
chance I think the chance accidents
Randomness stochasticity chaos are not
used they're bad form in psychoanalysis
and that that is the illustration of I
think for its assumption ultimately it's
it's an axiom it's a belief that it's
not questioned
if we were to translate that assumption
in the uh Kristen language this is the
longevon equation from which Christian
starts which is has notations by Daniel
thank you Daniel and we'll have the
change in the state of x equals the flow
plus the Omega
Omega is the stochastic component it's
the
uh you know in Daniel's metaphor we have
a wave and then we have Ripple
so we would have to change the
stochastic component if we were to go
with the Freud's Axiom and then if we do
that we would find ourselves squarely in
the domain of cold physics Newtonian
physics LaPlace is demon LaPlace
famously said give me a position and
momentum of every particle and I'll tell
you exactly where they have been before
and exactly where they will be in the
future now Freud didn't make statements
like that
but this is what would happen if you
kill the stochastic component
I want to be clear that it's not for its
fault at all well first of all you need
axioms to build a theory you chose that
Axiom that's the theory he built and
second of all it wasn't exactly
mathematics
and and finally the Zeitgeist of the
time was deterministic you know perhaps
they were uh you know initial
derivations of stochastic mechanics and
quantum mechanics but for it when he was
learning the world of deterministic
physics was dominant
and uh there's an important Nuance in
this discussion pointed out to me by the
first peer reviewer of the paper who
said You Know listen if you have
something that changes like a stochastic
thing and then you apply statistics to
it such as variance then the variance of
a changing variable will be
deterministic
and then if we look at things like verbs
which are used a lot in talk therapy
like Apple
when Apple is a semantic memory it's a
category it's a course grading already
from green apples and red apples and all
other kinds of apples so in that regard
words are deterministic phase
so perhaps when we have a dream analysis
session and the patient shares with an
analyst you know the movie that they saw
the messy you know irrational thing with
images and tunes and anything and maybe
words even if they narrate it
then they they slow things down they
average things out and they put it in
deterministic tools which is words
so with some objects we can apply
deterministic tools but I want to point
out that the foundation that everything
and anything in the psychic-wise that
all the limitations have no statisticity
Randomness is a very strong assumption
and I'm curious what would happen if we
were to
allow ourselves to see things on the
sphere on the parabolic shape it's not a
bad exercise because the uh general
theory of relativity would not have
existed between without these other
geometries
uh in terms of definitions this is a
familiar formula that you mark use of
Shannon's entropy he originally wrote
about Telegraph and Sandra and receiver
in a fixed alphabet but here if we draw
an attracting set which happens to be
lorenza tractor in Phase space and we
look at these I don't know if you can
see them they're small the white points
you know that's the initial condition
and then they spread out and evolve as
time goes by but you can see the density
of the attracting set it is a higher
density and lower density so we could
calculate uh probability distribution
uh a slightly different question is this
what would happen if you were to change
the initial condition a little bit well
one millimeter in Phase space
different things can happen and one of
them is shown in this diagram that would
be diverges
in the formula here's initial condition
multiplied by exponent of Lambda T so
when Lambda is positive you have
Divergence and it's called weapon of
exponent and that's one of the criteria
for chaos
when it is negative we have convergence
and when it is zero we have equidistant
trajectories we have Newtonian mechanics
right
this is an illustration of a chaotic
system which is a Great Red Spot on
Jupiter
and it fits perfectly the first things
paper about the Markov blankets and
stochastic chaos because that thing is
stable we have been observing it for 300
years and one could say that this
elliptical shape is the mark of blanket
around the chaos that maintains its
integrity
it's not a contradiction because in one
spatial scale you have marker blanket
and on another spatial scale you have a
chaos within Mark of blank
this is a convergent system that is a
bit trivial to all of you this is a hole
in the ground and then surrounded by
heels on all sides
and if you were to put a ball on the
hill it's going to roll down in the
potential well and typically in face
space we'll call the bottom of the hole
and a tractor and we call the heels
repeller repeller is a term uh less
frequently used but you know it's the
highly unstable point in Phase space
from which things move away from and
they move toward the attractor
now that's just one attraction the
interesting things start happening if
you've got two of them imagine a second
hole immediately to the right and the
boundary between them may very quickly
become chaotic
there's another illustration on a
convergent system from the active
inference textbook that I hadn't read
when I was working on the paper I
discovered it later
the chart on the left is the density and
again we see high density in the center
and we hate lower density in the
periphery and the chart on the right is
surprise we're very not surprised to
find a ball in the center and we're very
much surprised if it stays on the hill
and I'll read you a citation active
inference is restricted to systems like
that one on the left which count to
random fluctuations with their average
flow and thereby retain their form over
time
it may sound like the statement
contradicts what I said earlier that Fab
is compatible with chaos but it doesn't
because you could have different spatial
scales and convergence on one scale and
Divergence in another I also
historically think that we have been
studying converging systems mostly so
far
now if we move from things like that
which is very simple
through a mind or Consciousness then I
think that what which could be looking
at is this that's a landscape with
attractors and repellers
that is very complex and I'm going to
quote the former president of the coast
Society for psychology is that that
landscape is dynamic it moves
uh perhaps some things on it are stable
before imagine a clinical scenario where
there's a patient who is very prone to
shame
and very verse to express anger then we
could say that shame is an attractor and
anger is a repeller but and we work with
pattern things in dynamic therapy so
they could be relatively stable until
the work in therapy makes them more
shallow distributions but certain things
change overnight some things change in a
week or during the course of therapy so
I mean strictly speaking that's a
dynamic landscape and I don't think we
model things this way
um I'd like to also quote Maxwell
ramstead from the same paper that free
energy principle is a tale of two
densities it would be incomplete to say
that we just minimize one variable
you know uh what happens is we minimize
the Shannon's entropy of probability
distribution over sensor States while at
the same time we maximize entropy of
internal beliefs which is very important
that's adaptation if somebody has rigid
internal beliefs
with sharp probabilities and then covet
happens they will have lower probability
of survival
they're not adaptable so adaptability
means maximization of entropy of
internal beliefs while maintaining the
four means the minimization of Shannon
xanthropy of probability distribution
over sensory States
uh here's another term comogorov
cyanthropy that is not intuitive and
it's from topology
the picture you see is the photograph of
the statue called intuition outside the
fields Institute of mathematics in
Toronto and here's a graphical
illustration if you were to draw the
trajectories in face space
and surrounded by certain volume say a
circle with a radius Epsilon
and asked herself what happens to this
volume as they evolve
well when when the when it expands then
you can have characteristicity when it
uh becomes more compact you could have
convergence when it stays the same you
have periodic system which is indicated
on the chart on the right where you have
you know a correlative they call
logarithm entropy on the y-axis and you
have this Epsilon on the x-axis so the
flat line at the bottom where the the
circle doesn't change is the periodic
system homographs an entropy stays zero
the curved line in the center that
converges on a k is the proper chaos
this is theoretical chaos and the
options from it uh is is what friston
calls stochastic chaos this is cares
plus noise and then you can have pure
nodes and then you can have pure
linearity so all of these things exist
they're all on the table you can have
geometry on the plane geometry in the
sphere geometry in the parabolic shape
so what is the data show
and uh when we look at EG entropy people
use approximate enthropy permutation
entropy and Spectrum entropy which are
all derivations of coma chorusinai and
the first two are in a different face
space from the last one I believe Mark
correct me if I'm wrong your side go
series uh a study in your book Hidden
Spring when you talk about entropy and
phases of sleep and they use Spectrum
entropy which is a derivation of
chromogorovsinai in the frequency domain
analysis phase space
so the data shows that you know uh
assistance for as small as a axon of a
squid isolated in the lab to single
neurons two coupled neurons to EEG
we have evidence of positive lack of lap
enough exponents in some regimes of
operation with EEG we can be more
specific that Alpha Rhythm seems to be
weakly non-linear
while things below Alpha like Delta seem
to be more periodic with noise and
things above Alpha such as gamma and
high gamma seem to be chaotic
so if we were to summarize this data
that it would
be we can say that komogorously enthropy
appears to increase as generalized
arousal increases from Delta to gamma
rhythm
seems to be higher in healthy alert
brain mind functioning than in the
states of coma Seashore deep sleep and
it can stay close to zero in a coma or
deep sleep the interesting anecdote here
is that a simple Act of closing your
eyes when you're alert decreases
commodore cinethropy
clinical applications are vast and
developing fast for example but except
for Clinical Psychology I must say in
Psychiatry psychotherapy but in
neurology the seizure detection on the
EEG is right now can be done with AI
with about the same accuracy as a human
neurologist and that algorithm does use
characteristicity assessment there's
models for Parkinson's neuropathic pain
and other have other examples that I'll
skip right now
this is a graphical illustration of
phases of sleep
and again it has called mogorithm
anthropy as a phase of sleep it shows
wakefulness and then shallow sleep
progressively deeper sleep and REM and
that's the time Evolution if you move
Ram in frequency to where it belongs to
wakefulness then you'll see the same
progression that golma grows in the
entropy appears to increase as a
function of generalized arousal
this is a seizure onset at about second
floor
teacher is a reduction in keraticity
healthy functioning is higher
characteristic than a seizure
this is a coma which is relatively
invariant fat in Delta frequency this is
a nearly periodic system with some noise
and death is a linear system it doesn't
change
this is persistent vegetative state
minimally conscious state where
researchers were asking a question on
prognosis of survival and they've
concluded that diversity and variability
of the EEG was the predictor of survival
higher entropy means life
so the hypothesis is that chaotic
stochastic and linear processes as well
as hybrid ones such as primarily chaotic
function with noise can be present
concurrently at different scales of the
brain mind
or the same scale but in different
places or at different times I realize
it's a mouthful but it fits the data
presented in the paper
this is again a picture from the
textbook and after your inference by
Thomas Parr Carl friston and Giovanni
passulo it's a cortical column and the
errors you see here
ascending and descending connections if
by chance you're not familiar with the
framework they correspond to uh the
ascending errors are prediction errors
and descending ones are predictions this
is what they say in the book
but there's an asymmetry and message
passing and the reason for that is that
the operations required to compute
prediction error from expectations are
non-linear this non-linearity is due to
computation of predictions using
non-linear functions that tend to
increase the frequency of the signal
I'd like to talk a little bit about
reduction it became very fashionable and
sometimes silly to you know use this
like oh your reduction is now your
reduction is done the second most
popular term is oversimplify you'll
oversimplify now you oversimplifying to
me they're not bad words and they're
necessary tools to simplify and to
reduce uh you know the map that equals
the territory exactly is useless
nobody's going to use it it must kind of
I'm quoting James Glick simplify and
abstract
but you know I'll illustrate the the
specific term
if the car is moving with a fixed
velocity in a straight line and if I
know exactly where it is right now I can
tell with certainty where it has been an
hour before that is a reduction in time
and I can do that because the formula is
linear its distance equals velocity
multiplied by time and velocity is
constant
if the watch is broken and I disassemble
it and I find a faulty part and then I
put it back together
uh and it works then it's a reduction in
space and I can do that because watch is
not an ant colony to use Daniel's terms
which is equal to the collection of its
parts
so I wanted to talk about Mark your uh
mention of the predictive hierarchy
composed of billions of homeostats in
your in your work
and this is approximate picture this is
not the exact picture of what you talk
about in a new project and this is from
your Hidden Spring
it's a predictive hierarchy where
predictions flow from left to right and
prediction errors from right to left
and one of the statements in the book of
The Hidden Spring you say that brains
many complex functions really can
ultimately be reduced to a few simple
mechanisms like this so it appears that
you you know you call it reduction
but I just wanted it is a powerful model
it is a flexible model I wanted to
describe some features of it well first
of all if homeostat is present at every
single scale then we have this
homogeneity of mechanism throughout
these scales
and I want to say that in physics things
don't look this way quantum mechanics is
the microphysics statistical mechanics
is a molecular level Newtonian mechanics
is heavenly bodies and then we have
general theory of relativity there's
qualitative shifts that is in the
homogeneity of mechanism all the way
throughout in fact when people say take
entanglement and they apply to human
beings that's sort of a misunderstanding
or entanglement
uh the second comment is from Michael
Levin who talks about these scales and
if you know his comment is that you
could have different functional spaces
at every scale where you could solve the
genetic task on one scale
electrochemical in another morphological
than the third one and then how you do
message passing what is the common
language it's not a trivial question
along the same lines I've already
mentioned that a message between the
scales can be non-linear if you do
prediction errors now if you take one
non-linear message and then you multiply
it by billions you're going to have a
full on turbulence which is a chaotic
system it's a dynamical system and
turbulence you cannot reduce the
homeostat or anything else you know
saying that water consists of H2O does
not explain turbulence
so I don't know that's an open question
but I wanted to maybe share some
perceptions of this model this I talked
about uh and this is the for instance
thought about phase transition and the
attracting set he said that if you have
a hierarchy of lorenza structures a
slower one and a faster one
and just lower one governing the
transitions of the faster lorenza
tractor and then you could have a pep
formulation with an attracting set
experiencing changes and transitions
and that's brilliant I think and it
matches the anatomy because the brain
stem and the subcortical structures
appear to be slower lorenza tractor that
could be seen as governing the
transitions of the cortex which is
astrological
I know I'm oversimplified things a great
deal but it sort of this is his thoughts
I think him and Lancelot Acosta are
working on that perhaps Maxwell
ramstad's group is working on that as
well
the clinical applications the landscape
that I've mentioned before would be
absolutely lovely to see if it were to
consider going there
uh borderline personality disorder or
another term for that could be complex
trauma the metaphor that we use for
these patients is they're predictably
unpredictable that the only thing we
know on Wednesday that we don't know
what's going to come up suggesting
characteristicity acute trauma has a
symptom of hyperarousal suggesting
possibly higher level of chaoticity an
onset of mania can be seen as a
transition into a higher energy State
and addiction is particularly with
stimulants can be seen as phase
transitions into a geologic state
it may sound like what I said now is
contradictory to the what I said before
when I suggested that you know lower
characteristicity could be a problem
such as an onset of a seizure and here
I'm saying higher chaoticity can be a
problem but that would only be a
contradiction in the linear world in the
real world where linear is very small
percentage of what's happening I'm
saying both that too little and too much
caves could be a problem
just enough chaos imbalance could be
perfectly fine
this is a graphical illustration of what
can be done and this is from my
colleague and friend David Pinkus who is
a professor in Chapman University and I
think also former president of the
society for chaos and psychology Society
these are trees and may sound like
completely unrelated to what we do
except if you look at the human lung or
a dendrites in a neuron and you can see
a healthy Tree on the right from me and
the nearly dead tree on the left
and if you do the fractal assessment
fractal Dimension assessment on them by
counting the thickness of branches and
count the number of branches at each
level
then you can quantify
and you then you can have approximate
quantification of health and resilience
versus you know pathology
and again as exotic as it may sound this
is very similar to what people do when
they detect a seizure on the AG they
measure CD correlational Dimension which
is approximately a fractal dimension
and
I think my 30 minutes are up thank you
so much for your attention
thank you Lexi gray presentation well
looking forward to this discussion first
Mark please feel free to add your
Reflections then Andrea then we'll
continue on
thanks very much
um
I when Alexi asked me if I would join
this panel uh the first thing that I
said to him was yes uh coupled with the
second thing being but please be aware
that I know next to nothing about Chaos
Theory so you know I'm not sure
how much uh of a contribution I can make
to a technical discussion
um of
this kind uh so I'm just repeating that
uh before I say anything else if I say
anything that sounds amateur that it
sounds as if this guy doesn't know what
he's talking about when it comes to
Chaos Theory it's because I'm an amateur
and I don't know what I'm talking about
when it comes to chaos theory
that said
um the second thing I want to say is I'm
not entirely sure what is at stake uh
here you know it seems as if Alexi feels
that it's really important that um that
I and uh our colleagues uh get our head
around chaos theory and bring
um some of its um what it has to offer
uh into our field
um because I don't know much about it I
don't know what's at stake you see I
don't know uh why that's important so uh
um you know perhaps somewhere along the
line in the next uh just less than an
hour that we have perhaps Alexi you can
clarify that for us
um the third thing I wanted to say is
um and perhaps in order to illustrate
the first thing is that as Alexi was
talking now it seemed as if he was
talking about chaos as if it were
synonymous with stochasticity or or
Randomness uh and that's not my
understanding my very limited
understanding of chaos theory was that
it's not a synonymous chaos as used in
that um in that science or in that
theory
um is not synonymous with with
Randomness it's rather synonymous with
unpredictability
um because we don't know the initial
conditions of the system what we can't
specify all the variables with
sufficient Precision uh in their initial
conditions it becomes impossible to
predict
um and and because of the nature of the
interrelated relationships of the
variables one tiny little error in your
estimation of the initial conditions can
lead to massive consequences and this is
why it's so hard to predict uh chaotic
systems
so if that is what is meant then I would
say
um of course this applies to the way
that the mind works and the way that the
brain works
um but that leads me back to my second
point I'm not sure what's at stake but I
would say if that's what you're asking
if that's what you're claiming rather uh
Alexi then I would say that's that
surely must be so that it is exceedingly
difficult to predict
um mental and neural events at any level
of complexity
um now uh I think I've said three things
let me now say a fourth thing
um I think that a crucial
um well let me put it this way uh of
course what the brain and mind are
trying to do
um
it's a matter of trying to predict
what's going to happen so when I what
I've just said about how how difficult
it is uh to predict what's going to
happen in the brain or mind it's it's
it's it's almost the same thing as to
say uh that the the mind and brain are
trying to model the world uh that's
that's the main thing that we're trying
to do is is is is uh have a good model
of the world so that we can get some
sort of grip uh on this chaos
um so that we can act rationally in the
sense that we can act
um in order to preserve ourselves that
we do not dissipate uh by uh just uh
exploring all possible States and and no
longer existing as a system because we
as systems need to remain within certain
bounds across a great many variables as
you said
um we can't afford to just let should
happen and you know and throw ourselves
uh uh to its uh to to to its Fates uh we
need to try to predict uh in a very
unpredictable world uh what must I do in
order to meet this need given how the
world works so the brain is trying to
model the world uh our predictive model
uh is is is trying to synchronize itself
with the world and for that reason it's
going to be very chaotic
um but the crucial point is it's trying
to reduce uh the unpredictability
um with that said uh I'll make a fifth
point or maybe it's another part of my
fourth point no I think it's a fifth
point which is that the way that I
conceptualize the predictive model and
it's not me alone who does this is that
it is a hierarchical model
um and I think that's very important and
perhaps here's where things do start
where it starts to um at least in my
mind I start to see some of what's at
stake
um I I think that the more peripheral
layers of the predictive model I see the
predictive model as a as a not as a
triangle but rather as an onion so the
core that is the the deepest layers of
the model that is to say
um the the layers that have the um the
greatest
um spatial and temporal generalizability
um and they're the most stable layers of
the model and as we move toward the
periphery which coincides with the
periphery
um of the of the nervous system in other
words the encounter with the outside
world
um
so it becomes more chaotic we are able
to we can tolerate
um more unpredictability at the
periphery uh and uh we we're trying to
and that's and that also allows for
greater accuracy because the world is so
unpredictable we have a more more
chaotic uh um outer layer of our
predictive model where where things also
there's less that's at stake you know is
that car going to turn left or right
well I thought it was going to turn left
turn right so what doesn't matter you
know but
um it is the law going to is the car
going to obey the laws of gravity that
that matters more you know that's not
something uh that that's a a much more
consequential surprise uh if it if it
does not
um and perhaps that's a silly uh analogy
but at least it demonstrates the general
Point our most heartfelt beliefs
um and um uh that is to say the deepest
layers of our of our predictive
hierarchy there we find the same
patterns over and again and we we we we
find ourselves we we are more certain
um of our predictions and we act more
stereotypically in accordance with them
uh whereas uh at the periphery uh that
does not apply so I think um at one
point in your presentation Alexi you you
were saying something like you know one
size doesn't fit all it's not all just
one mechanism all the way down uh of
course I completely agree with that
um the the the it's not just one
mechanism and the different homeostats
that you were referring to on their
different scales are also serving
different needs you know and there's
there's not a common currency uh I I
think that's a very important part of um
of how Consciousness works why we have
qualier at all is because we can't
introduce things to a common currency
we're dealing with categorical variables
at the very least in relation to our
bodily needs they are categorically
distinct needs and they need to be
treated as such and this is why we have
different feelings in relation to these
different uh categories of of free
energy
so um those are those are some of the
main things
um I I wanted to say just to get the
ball rolling I'm mindful of the fact
that Andrea clarichi uh only has uh 15
more minutes with us so um maybe we can
pick I can pick up on some other points
later uh but at this stage let me hand
over to Andrea thank you
can you hear me now
yes sorry I will try also to articulate
something of the very fascinating paper
of Alexia I must confess since I'm also
a psychonalytic psychotherapist a
psychiatrist it's not my field I'm not a
physicist so I can really say a few
words
some is of as I said already Fascination
because in general I hate to stick to
rigid theories so if there is a paper
like Alexia who can counter size my
theories even in psychoanalysis
in the workings of the mind and the
Brain I'm happy to to to to to dive into
it
at the same time uh I unders I I don't
have the skills to to to to discuss the
the math part of his papers or even the
the physical formulas and so on
but I was reminded of a very early and
you I think you all know that book uh
Jacques monod chants a necessity which
is a classic
and I think it's a book in which you uh
you can
from from scratch I mean here that we
our aim in the world and I I I'm I know
I'm talk I'm sounding
teleological but we have theological uh
um teleological uh AIMS in order to stay
alive we have to face chance and cows so
I think this is
uh in order to survive and reproduce we
have to uh have a mathematical system to
reduce chaos and to bring up again the
terminism or psychic determinism since
one of the of the points that lexier I
think raised is do can this can we still
hold the point of Freud's about psychic
determinism
and I think if you apply not to the
physics of of just materialism of of of
things actually but to the living
organism I think we do this is my point
and I I would like to uh to
hear what Alexia says in the end
the chaos theory mathematics
as far as I understand it must be in
mathematics who reduce chance or chaos
to uh to a linearity at least in the in
the living organism
and I and I wonder if
and what Alexei thinks about it
because you seems to disagree with that
want to give a direct response Lexi or
pen brain and Albert be awesome to hear
your takes as well some of the thoughts
from Mark and from Andrea
today she started by responding to
Andreas Owen's remarks or
yeah
maybe I'll start by because I think the
key point that Mark you brought up is
what's at stake is still unclear my
impression isn't please correct me if
I'm wrong I was very influenced marked
by your paper I forgot exactly the
journal where you talked about
Psychiatry world how these sort of you
know convention-based diagnosis of fear
is a major depressive disorder here's a
bipolar disorder nothing which has to do
with etiology you know uh convention and
statistics you know and then you brought
up this you know revolutionary thing
with effective Neuroscience where you
talked about the manic State and the
depression State and you know tied into
the punk step system I think is
extraordinary but what I wanted to say
is you know if we look at how we
diagnose and think about what's
happening and we look at the language of
how we do it it is still a deterministic
language at the end of the day so when
we move from dsm-4 to DSM-5 we
brilliantly discovered that continuous
variables exist we used to have buckets
everything was in a separate bucket and
then we said autism as a spectrum and
everybody applaud it but you know
mathematicians were quietly laughing in
the corner you know because of course
continuous variables exist and but we
don't do Dynamics we're still very
static here's this clear-cut thing and
this is the clear-cut continuous thing
right and I'm my impression I may be
wrong is that even in in our
neuropsychonalytic developments we still
do things deterministically we assess
which bucket things belong to maybe two
buckets at the same time or three
buckets but we don't do things like
you know how the chaotic systems are
qualitatively different from aesthetic
things I'm quoting William Solis they
have transients they have contextuality
and they have emergence
we don't do that you know and uh I think
that if we embrace the chaos theory if
we do things like correlational
Dimension assessment or fractal
Dimension assessment starting from this
system of classification of emotions
they're still buckets here is a
clear-cut thing called fear and that's a
clear-cut thing called rage buckets
determinism okay and you know they look
differently in the dynamical systems
world and then the system of
Psychopathology could look like you know
correlational Dimension changed and not
that somebody fell into a bucket you
know if we look at this complex you know
landscape of attractors and repellers
and examine psychodynamic things like
please forgive me if I'm incorrect uh um
but one of the possible definitions of
repression could be seen as not letting
things into Consciousness maybe we can
call it suppression but what I'm trying
to say is I don't want to think that
right now it hurts it's a painful thing
that in in the terminology that I shared
is a repeller and perhaps when you work
through things in a Dynamic
psychotherapy perhaps you put a scar
tissue on the wound it becomes less of a
Sharp you know uh repeller and it
Smooths out
you know we don't talk we don't diagnose
like that we don't trip like that we
don't think like that
uh one paper that I'm working on that is
in in peer review right now and I can't
share too much says that you know we
think like storytellers I'm quoting
Daniel kahnemann our our you know think
in Mind of a clinician is not a
statistician we don't think in
probabilities we think in labels and we
think in stories and I know you have
this powerful quote mark from Freud who
said that that's the nature of the mind
and I most respectfully disagree that
that's the entire nature of the mind I
do think that we have things on the mind
that are not stories and not words so
ain't the nature of the phenomena is
chaotic and stochastic and periodic then
we can use appropriate mechanisms to
diagnose and classify uh that fits the
the nature of the model
the second thing you said case is
stochasticity I absolutely agree with
you that they're different you know the
chart that I've shown if you converge to
a stable uh stochastic chaos is
deterministic for a deterministic so if
initial conditions are changing they
will diverge but you can predict things
forward not back but uh there is no
formula in a stochastic thing you know
you throw the coin you don't know you
have no predictability whatsoever short
term or third or long term so they are
different and in the sense that you're
talking to sensitivity to initial
conditions this is music to my heart to
hear you to say that you acknowledge
that irriticity clearly is present of
the brain on which level of the
hierarchy in your model is a very
important thing but again when we draw
this picture whether it's a triangle or
an onion with a core and layers it's a
static model
now when you acknowledge that there's
higher and predictability toward the
periphery it could be but there could be
Dynamics about the structure of the
model and perhaps what you're saying is
survival you know like I must breathe
and I must breathe air and I'm not in
the water and that is a very stable
prediction absolutely but when we deal
with Psychopathology and we deal with
things like shame and pride and awe and
other things then I wonder if we should
continue to use this metaphor of
homeostat I really don't see how
homeostat applies to gamma rhythm in the
brain or to shame
so and homeostat is is the convergent
systems so that you you minimize entity
by keeping things in the rage however if
you dive inside the homeostat if you
look at the temperature variation inside
our narrow range you may see chaos which
is exactly the picture that I saw so
um that I showed um
hmm
and to Andrea's point is about the
Freud's principle of psychic determinism
yes I almost was thinking that we
haven't said goodbye to that we haven't
tried to say that chance exists in the
mental life accidents exist we don't do
that
there's a firm tradition in and
psychonautic Psychotherapy to say
there's no accidents it's all determined
that's a major key point of the
discussion
I don't know if I said too much
maybe Andrea if you want to give any
yes or how do you how do you want things
to continue in the coming minutes and
years okay thank you thank you Daniel uh
just adding a word that I didn't use
because I think it's very important
about trying to defend the point about
psychic determinism which I'm I'm very
fond of I mean the word is adaptation I
have difficulties in because when you
see a psychotic patient when you see a
borderline patient well I don't see
chaos or total unpredictability idea the
adaptation
their disruptions
uh I I try to to to to to understand
what are the even the mathematics the
mathematical part be behind that
in my opinion has to have a
tendency to over an order which is
adaptive in this way I see uh the the
mathematical part of of chaos may be of
use I mean but bringing
uh to an explanation not to maybe not to
an order or to a determinism but to a
point in which uh there must be this
adaptive reason even in the chaos
do you see my point
I do but I think there's a deeper issue
about how we think you know say there's
a clinician psychologic psychotherapist
we have a work in memory and The
Miller's law that Mark you quote a lot
about the seven units of information uh
in the auditor what a verbal work in
memory I think in The Miller's paper he
actually said seven chunks so I'm
sharing something from the paper in
review right now we cannot think
probabilistically because it overloads
the working memory this is why when I'm
a clinician I think about psychosis I
come up with a story a formulation that
fits in the working memory and this
influences our work we don't have the
mathematics in here to think in the
terms of probabilistic things and Chaos
Theory and other things we need tools to
do that and in mainstream neurology they
use tools they do talk to the patient
that examine the patient but they have
MRI they have ehe they have pestican and
all the other things inside chronic
Psychotherapy will say we don't need any
tools we just talk to a person that is
sufficient for everything we do but
that's not necessarily true the entries
be B who is a psychoanalyst works with
Mother infant diet and there's zero
words exchanged zilch but she looks at
this movie that she records on a video
camera and then she throws it shows it
in a slow motion so she takes the flow
which is dynamic flow not words not
discrete things and then she slows it
down and she slows the level of
Attunement between the mother and the
child
we don't do things like that
we talk and we use these deterministic
things to understand the Psychopathology
of the patients in not psychosis and
that's schizophrenia and that is bipolar
one this Hispanic system and this is
seeking system we determinize everything
and that is a limitation because inside
I believe what is a fear Cascade how
does Fear stop it's a flow it's a
turbulent thing and we put one label in
it say fear we've classified it so for
some things it's appropriate but for
some things it may not be it may be you
know as as you know Einstein said as
Mark you quoted Einstein as simple as
possible but more simpler than that so
at which point we are missing with or
missing the phenomenon by using
deterministic Tools in our work
thank you thank you thank you Daniel and
Mark to everyone thank you I have to go
awesome
so Albert
and then Brennan will continue on this
topic
um
yeah thank you for the presentation and
a very interesting discussion so far
um one thing that comes to mind is the
um
the the well
the thing we're talking about right now
the psychic determinism as as uh
depicted as being a foundational line
psychoanalysis
um
well I'm thinking about the authors the
psychoanalytic authors who came The
prominent ones who came after Freud
uh who seem to have uh
uh who have room
or this this chaos maybe they didn't use
this term
explicitly but I'm thinking for example
Wilfred Beyond who's got the notion of
the O layer
um which has connotations of uh well the
thing that
I cannot be known or categorized who has
like in indeterminate elements of the
mind and that's one of his major
contributions contributions to
psychoanalysis on the other hand the
more the French schools I'm thinking of
Jack Lacon who's got the notion of the
real which is also one of his major
contributions contributions to
psychoanalysis where Notions of rupture
of absence or of lack are very prominent
I'm not sure I'm not an expert here but
I think
explicitly uh challenges the notion of
Freud's mechanistic worldview in one of
its seminars
so I'm wondering what you think about
this Alexei
hey I'm not an expert in lacan at all
and I know Wilfred Beyond in a limited
fashion so perhaps Mark is a better
person to to to uh to talk and I I like
for it particularly it marks
interpretations and translations but
maybe Mark can comment on lacan and
Beyond I I'm not sufficiently
knowledgeable about that they work
if you want to mark
or Brin you can share some thoughts yeah
please
um well I think that uh um the the point
that Elder is making that is we must
remember that psychoanalysis is not
synonymous with Freud
um that not everything in psychoanalysis
stands or Falls by whether or not we
accept this or that tended to Freud's
um and uh in neuropsychoanalysis we try
very much to draw upon all of the
Traditions uh within psychoanalysis and
we we sort of uh fondly believe that
we'll be able to find more a common
ground because they are greater
empirical tools available in
neuropsychoanalysis than in
psychoanalysis by itself you know we're
we're hoping to resolve some of these uh
theoretical disagreements trying to move
Beyond just different systems of belief
trying to move more toward a a
psychoanalysis in which we can decide
questions in an ordinary scientific way
but it will always be very difficult for
exactly the reason that Alexis whole
talk is about I suppose which is you
know the the extreme complexity uh and
therefore
um unpredictability uh of the of the
phenomena that we're dealing with
um so I think Albert's points are valid
uh that uh the Beyond's approach lacon's
approach
um they they add a great deal that they
they don't um they don't
um have as much to to lose if we throw
out the principle of psychical
determinism
um but having said that let me just
quickly say a word about psychical
determinism because this has been a a
big part of what uh Andrea picked up on
on in what Alexi said
um I I think it comes down to the the
the question that I asked at the outset
it's not a matter of is the behavior of
the Mind random uh or uh it's it's a
it's a question of how predictable uh
it's not a matter of is there no
determinism it's a matter of how easily
can we Trace effects back to their
causes
um so the fact that there's a great deal
that goes on where we can't do that uh
there are many things our patients say
whether they be slips of the tongue or
anything else of that kind and not only
to do with parapraxes but anything that
they do you know there's certain things
that we see with regularity I mean the
very phenomenon of transference is all
about regularities that there's certain
things that we see Yep this size this I
pre this I I can understand
um this happens repeatedly uh I I I I
think I can explain that with reference
to uh certain aspects of the patients in
a world and and their past but there's a
great deal else that we can't so I don't
think that it's a kind of you know
either there's determinism or there's or
there's a statisticity I think that
there's this is why I was talking also
about the layers of the predictive
hierarchy that the the deeper layers or
the unconscious ones their things are
pretty pretty stereotyped
um pretty pretty predictable in fact
too predictable I mean in other words
it's over generalizes it it's it it's
it's too confident about its beliefs
um but as we head toward uh the
pre-conscious and conscious peripheries
you know their things are much less
predictable
um so that that's I I won't say more
about this a couple of things in what
Alexi said in his uh in his comments
after mine that that if we have time
I'll come back to you but I I think
let's rather hear from from Bryn before
I I say anything more yeah I think thank
you so much
um I I I'm perhaps the least qualified
here to to comment on your on your paper
uh Alexi um but I do have one or two
thoughts and they they come from a place
of being
very fortunate uh thus far in my life to
have been a patient from for many many
hours
um
um sometimes on the couch and also to be
a clinical psychologist I failed to
mention that at the at the in my
introduction so I'm I'm a clinician I
was a until recently uh when my foray
began into more
um research based areas and by the
active uh inference Institute and Mark's
Work and uh and and and and and called
Kristen's work I was a a pure clinician
I had it in my mind that I was going to
treat Psychopathology to the best of my
ability and but really it was being a
patience first and foremost that brought
me into closer contact with the the
theme of your paper and certainly the
themes of Mark's Work
um and
um
I think I've encountered it from both
areas and it certainly
um
it matters to to my mind it matters less
the inner workings of the degree to
which uh chaos a stochastic uh all these
big wonderful terms that that I'm only
beginning to to even think about but
um oh
what what's what matters to me is that
how do you help somebody
uh who is in a in a state who comes in
disheveled and and and you know how does
one go about helping uh aiding somebody
in that state
um I have um fell out of love with
psychoanalysis uh for for personal
reasons
um but it was in returning to it I've
become more kind of a better acquainted
with its strengths and its limitations
and I'm realizing that
it's um
it's that when you help somebody and
manage to reduce the noise to reduce uh
the chaos in somebody's mind
um that they that when they become the
greater degrees of Health start
returning to them that they they do rely
far more whether they know it or not on
probabilistic reasoning in their daily
um kind of functioning
um and so I think there is a strong case
to be made for a mathematical uh way of
processing the world it doesn't have to
necessarily be conscious made conscious
to the person
um it can be a bit overwhelming to uh to
try and impart that on somebody but um I
think a brain that is not working
properly uh regardless of the degree to
which there is chaos that can be
measured or quantifiably uh measured in
that brain somebody isn't is tripping
over themselves because they
um they've they are unable to predict
what might happen and and that is a
terrifying Prospect because I think
there is a some Reliance and some some
staunch dependability on the the fact
that the sun is going to rise and that
it's going to set and that I can then
focus on other things uh um
so that's just the my comments more from
kind of a personal front of being a a
patient uh and and encountering the
limitations of psychotherapy and what
what I would have
what I would have done in those moments
of need to have not as you say had a
more a deterministic view of what was
happening and I've tried to
um transfer that or carry that over
rightly or wrongly
um into my own therapy as a
psychotherapist as
um
um so a more personal thing of what it
means to be to feel chaotic and what I
see regardless of how confirmed it is
um you know or not
um but but chaos Reigns and and it's to
try and
not compound that uh it's certainly
something that um I'm interested in
so yeah thank you Bryn
I'll also give my thought on what's at
stake and what's on the table as a total
non-clination but what I saw in Alexis
paper and also what I see people coming
towards
I see the paper as Alexi making a a real
stable of concept or portfolio of topics
ranging from the first principles of
active inference like surprise bounding
to Dynamic stochastic chaotic which is
not the same thing but they sometimes
cohabitate so bringing a set of Concepts
into play making it matter for the field
so that it can matter for the clinician
so that it can matter for the patient
which is where you totally brought it
home to Bryn and in my totally
simplified model I was seeing all this
diagnostic Machinery from personalized
data EEG recordings all these surveys
and samples all the different
conversation therapy itself all these
different measurements inference
and then it passes through the Markov
blanket of the diagnosis and it's like
well now we know that that person is X
or the half X
and then here's where we now Branch back
out with the modalities of of treatment
and so that bottlenecking has obvious
relevance in terms of like getting a
categorical grip on what we basically
all agree are wet wear complex systems
they're sensitive to initial conditions
all of that
and
what if though like you brought up the
example with a scar tissue maybe it's
literal bodily Scar Tissue maybe it's
conceptual Scar Tissue what if that
inference were able to be understood in
the context of an attractor landscape
and it's not just a singular attractor
so we have multiple tractors
we have a chaotic landscape
and so what if we were able to
um perforate that blanket speaking super
Loosely to bring in what we have already
recognized as diagnostically relevant
like the fact that patients who have
differential entropy have this or that
epileptic outcome or a coma outcome
bring in that Machinery that led to the
diagnosis but now take it beyond the
diagnosis and maybe even beyond the
clinicians concept directly into the
hands of the patient
but
thank you so much perhaps we can hear
from Mark and yeah I am not eager to
talk I'll if there is time I'll say
something but if not that's okay
um well let me first of all say
something about my
um screen you might some of you have
noticed that suddenly everything went
black behind me that's because I had I'm
in South Africa where they have power
problems and then um a kind person in my
household thought that they would help
and they've put this huge Spotlight here
which is shining in my eyes and uh
um so um if if I if I look as if I'm in
a rabbit in headlights it's because I am
I sent a text message saying please come
and remove this big lamp you put here
but they don't seem to have received the
message
um now back to our our actual uh topic
um to the extent that I'm able to not be
distracted from it I think that um that
when I asked
um uh Alexi what was at stake
um his main answer uh was to do with a
diagnosis now I don't mean that he's
saying that that's all that's at stake
but I think he's saying this illustrates
what's at stake
um so I want to first of all make sure
that because I'm not sure who our
audience is and who's going to be
watching this in case anybody uh is
misunderstands uh I want to make clear
that in psychoanalysis we've long ago
moved away from DSM and ICD type
diagnosis uh we we we always thought
that um the the the nosology uh the the
psychiatric nursology was was who really
artificial and created divisions where
they don't exist in nature and we
replaced it with a far more Dynamic
approach to diagnosis and it's not just
a matter of labeling it's a matter also
of what kind of thought process lies
behind the diagnosis in other words
conceptualizing what's going on here
rather than saying this is a an instance
of personality disorder and I'll specify
which type you know we don't think like
that in psychoanalysis and and really we
never have
um in neuropsychoanalysis uh the the we
we build in that same tradition
um I think that what Alexia was uh was
worrying about is he's he's saying yeah
but you know you use you use systems uh
you you say that there's this very
there's a certain number of drives
um and you use those to pass what you
seeing clinically
and yes we do
um and we have to because you can't just
say what I'm seeing is chaos you know
what you've got to say is well what I'm
seeing is chaos but let me try my best
to find the deeper structure of this uh
and so what we do is much the same as
what I was saying earlier about how
brain and mind work likewise the
clinician's mind works that way we have
some deeper Concepts uh that organize
what we see and then more on the surface
uh we we we see uh the the complexity
you know in other words we don't think
that we can reduce a patient just to one
saying this patient has problems with
this drive or something it's not as
simple as that of course but we do start
with saying well these are the drives
these are the attractors uh to put it uh
in terms of the attractor landscape that
you're talking about these are the these
are the preferred States
um of the of the human phenotype you
know and and in mental life too they are
preferred States there's certain there's
certain attractors uh that that we're
trying to
um
stay in those in those um like for
example uh if fear we want to be safe we
don't want to feel fear uh you know with
respect to attachment bonding we want to
stay close to our uh to our attachment
figures we don't want to lose them with
respect to rage we we don't want to be
frustrated and have things standing in
our way we want to we want to be able to
have free access to the objects of our
needs and so on you know those are these
attractors and you know we we have great
difficulty staying in those in those
homeostatic bounds and uh so you know
it's a it is a dynamic a picture and
then it's a quick over over the question
of the of the different drives there's
the the highly individualized predictive
model that each one of us comes up with
in relay relation to those drives and in
relation to the conflicts between those
drives and so on so I think that um that
this way of thinking that we use in
psychoanalysis and neuropsychoanalysis
is already of the kind that Alex is
calling for so I think that what Daniels
just said is that it therefore perhaps
uh very important to make clear uh it's
that that he's offering us a language an
additional language an additional I
don't just mean language I should say an
additional set of Concepts uh and
um and a highly developed one which we
might find useful and so we should take
this on board that sounds very
convincing to me that if if that's
what's at stake here that that Alex is
saying this is a language that lends
itself to the phenomena that you study
and to the way in which you go about
studying it then it sounds to me as if
Alex is right
um so that's the main thing I wanted to
say in response to to his comments uh uh
in in relation to what I said
um so
um if anyone else wants to say anything
else that's that's good with me but
Alexi uh if if I've misunderstood and if
there's something else that you think is
at stake that I'm not getting now's your
chance to to to say it
well I I just wanted to to end the
conversation when you said that that if
this language might be of any even to
consider this language to to in our
future models I'm a happy man and
there's nothing else I need to say uh
and
um I just wanted to to say that these
are human things they're occupational
hazards some of the things I'm talking
about this paper I'm working on about
narrative stuff is that you know uh of
course you know it is much easier for us
to think in in uh categories now even
the psychoanalytic world you know what
what uh you know we do in in the old
let's take the mcquilliam system and the
previous one we used to say three levels
of functioning you know uh neurotic
borderline psychotic these are
categories
they're not DSM categories they're not
bipolar one but they're categories
nonetheless then we have character
Styles obsessive character style
histrionic character style their
categories okay so to some degree it's a
human condition to put things in
categories and I do think that this is
this is a very strong historical reasons
that we think this way we we this we're
we have generations of thinking this way
in categories and yes at the end of the
day when we paint a portrait of a
patient it's developed and it's like a
tapestry all of these things weave into
one another and it's complex
but we start from basic categories and
you know um
certainly if we consider that you know
some things can be transient there can
be emergence they're like that the
certain behavior in one context is in a
compulsion but it's not a compulsion in
another context and perhaps I'm saying
trivial things to clinician and to
clinicians and uh also what what dream
you said just a comment when you said as
a patient to reduce the noise and reduce
the case I detect the bias in the
language you see how we call you know
Psychopathology and DSM disorders
disorder is a bad word for us and I'm
trying to say chaos is healthy I spend
most of my day in gamma functioning
which is a chaotic State it's not a bad
thing so in the folk language chaos is a
bad word disorder is a bit I want to put
things in order and then perhaps we're
missing something what comes to mind is
I think Mark you had meetings with
Michael Levin and Ian mcgilchrist who's
you know big on talking about the
mechanistic you know logical linear
straight and narrow left hemisphere type
of course it's not left hemisphere but
that's the model versus holistic
sensorial
kind of right hemisphere artistic type
and we're missing the second part like
Daniel's background is surrounded by Art
where you know we
we spend less time in the right
hemisphere maybe maybe appropriately so
but I think that there's some things
that lend themselves to that level of
understanding and we would break things
we we we look at Psychopathology and
human suffering like it's a carburetor
sometimes where we again you know put it
in buckets that's my impression but what
you said uh is is wonderful and I I you
know I don't contradict with anything I
agree with everything you said Mark so
uh Alex if I can just um comment uh if
you know if I if it's almost like an arc
you know the the pot of gold at the end
of the arc is is the uh reduced chaos
the reduced noise in terms of the
patience from the patient's perspective
but how you get there ironically is
actually by inducing
um uh States of uh tolerable chaos
um and then kind of
re-reformulating that reconsolidating
that chaos
um so it's not that uh that from the you
know healing or growth or whatever the
patient might present to you for it has
everything to do with um
minimal or marginal chaos induction and
then you know reintegration of that so
it the whole process is is premised on
chaos but in bite-sized doses maybe one
could could say
right and just to finish up and then
I'll stop talking Jonathan schadler who
is you know and he's uh you know rightly
uh respected as a psychoanalytic
practitioner and teacher and writer uh
he recently said that take a patient x
with an analyst why
together the diet
as emergent properties
that is not the same thing as patient x
with the analyst Z
right and show me one study where we we
take that into account we don't
we just we just do random you know a
clinical trial then we do meta-analysis
of random clinical trial what technique
did the therapist use they used you know
whatever four-letter therapy they
applied nobody looks at the emerging
properties in a diet the this Matrix you
know between the two and that's the
language of dynamical systems this is
Daniel Friedman you know ant colony that
you know a single end doesn't build
Bridges and grow mushrooms and Colony
does all those things we don't talk
about emergence in psychoanalytic
Psychotherapy do we it's true it's also
a fundamental challenge after all you
can't replicate within one dyad or
across dyads in a finite world so so it
does point to fundamentals
in our last minutes if
um each would like to give some thoughts
where do we go as we now the option of
exponent away from each other in our
paths so maybe um Albert Brin Mark and
then Alexi
what are your overall thoughts
Reflections and then where are we
heading
go for it Albert
um yeah I was I was about to comment on
Alexey
um about the emerging properties thing
um it's it's it's kind of the same point
I made earlier
um
in in later psychologic theories do talk
about emerging properties
um but yes I think as what what
Professor sulbs just mentioned uh this
this language I mean
this this new set of Concepts makes it
very uh uh practical for us to
communicate
with each other because
psychoanalysis has a bad habit of
Reinventing new Concepts every every new
decade so it's
there's a lot of chaos to use that word
um within uh psychonalic uh discourse so
yeah but overall
I thought I'm very grateful I think this
was a very interesting talk so yeah
thank you
thank you yes so uh by by way of closing
uh remarks I I I agree with um actually
it seems to me that there's there's a
there's an abundance of agreement in
this meeting I I don't see uh any big
controversy um so uh that's nice
um the uh I think what Bryn said uh is
it really captures it I liked it because
it because what he said was so
experienced near you know he was just
describing what it feels like to be a
patient and and and and you know to be
in a state of and not knowing uh and
uncertainty as opposed to you know a
more stable kind of uh tranquility and
then the the the ability to uh to to
allow yourself to return to uncertainty
um if you've if you've um found uh
answers that are too simple and that
that are that are too static to allow
ourselves to go back into this state of
of not really knowing
um that's that I think really does
describe what what we try to do for our
patients what we have to remember
applies to ourselves not only because we
are ultimately patients too but because
it applies to how the mind works it
applies to science how science works you
know that we we do need to find order uh
but uh there is disorder out there and
so we're always at risk of coming
prematurely to a rigid system of belief
um and we have to return back to the
coal face and back to the chaos but
ultimately where we want to be is back
in in that Valley uh uh
um and uh so the as much as Alexis right
to remind us that at the uh that the the
the the highest levels of brain activity
um in many senses of the word uh are
entropic
um and that that's deep sleep and
seizures you know are are are bad things
as much as that's true nevertheless I
think that the great trend of the mind
it's it's it's one of its fundamental
working principles is where we're
wanting to be more certain to we want
life to be more predictable we don't
like to be in chaos
um and I think that that's an important
um
a thing to remember you know while we
are acknowledging the importance of of
chaos and and of the the highly
unpredictable nature of the world and of
the phenomena we study in our field
nevertheless we Retreat from it and and
for very good reasons so those are my
closing remarks and and thank you
and I'll be very brief uh Alexa yeah
just thank you for the paper and and uh
for uh having such a um strong focus on
the patient and non-psychopathic Well on
on human The Human Condition I I think
that's so nice to have that
um come out uh of the paper when at at
first glance it doesn't seem to be there
so thanks for making it so human and
then just uh Daniel for organizing and
and to uh spend time with Mark and
Albert uh it's it's a great pleasure so
thank you very much
Alexi final words
I want to thank everybody and Mark and
Brynn and Albert and Daniel Andrea thank
you this is I had a great fun and I'm
very grateful honestly for your uh help
and openness and flexibility one of the
other reasons is uh kind of the the time
will live in you've all Herrera made
that comment that the rate of change is
accelerating you know when we were
hunter-gatherers uncertainty was Norm
you wake up there's nothing in the
fridge you have to go hunt and we
tolerate an uncertainty better we could
put our worldly positions on the back
and then we started Living in the world
of iPads iPhones were bombarded with
information and we must minimize
uncertainty we must you know have
predictability in everything which is
not the natural world or mammals and now
you know we live our life and then vain
called it hits and then Bank you know
certain person becomes the president of
the United States you know and
everything goes upside down so uh the
black swans are hitting us more
frequently so I think having the theory
of that you know at our fingerprints and
applying guitar work is probably you
know beneficial but again thank you all
so much I really appreciate
awesome well thank you all for joining
the conversation continues so till next
time
my birth
foreign